[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
And today we have a
treat, Carol Barnes,
who's recognized for
groundbreaking research
in the neurophysiological
basis for changes in learning
and memory as humans age.
She directs the Evelyn
McKnight Brain Institute
as a regents professor in
psychology and neurology
and a fellow of the
American Association
for the Advancement of Science.
Carol earned her bachelor
of arts in psychology
from UC, Riverside,
her MA and PhD
from Carleton
University in Ottawa.
She has been conducting
brain-related research
for more than three decades.
Her work provides the
basis for understanding
the basic mechanisms of
normal aging in the brain
and sets a background
against which
it's possible to
assess the effects
of pathological changes,
such as Alzheimer's disease.
It's really important
to recognize
she was one of the
first people that
tried to put a baseline on what
it is to have normal aging.
You can't really
figure out if you're
sick if you don't know what the
normal baseline is all about.
So please welcome our
distinguished speaker today,
Carol Barnes.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for this
wonderful turnout.
It's wonderful to see
you all here tonight.
Now, if I can make the slides
work, we'll have a go here.
Yes.
One of the greatest
scientific puzzles, at least,
it's kept my attention
for many years,
is how the brain
captures and preserves
the unique experiences
of each individual.
This organ gives us
our own identity.
It gives us the
ability to understand
other great mysteries
that exist around us.
Now, the importance of memory
was appreciated, actually,
very early on.
For example, in
Egypt, the god Thoth,
shown here in
several depictions,
was the god of learning,
memory, and wisdom.
And in Egyptian mythology,
Thoth had the responsibility
of governing affairs
involving memory.
In Greece, it was Mnemosyne
who was the goddess of memory.
Mnemosyne was one of Zeus' wives
and the mother of the Muses,
the goddesses that were the
spiritual source of emotion
and the arts.
Amongst the earliest
written accounts
that describe the idea that
memory changes with age
come from Aristotle's treatise
On Memory and Reminiscence
of about 350 BCE.
He describes there why the
very young and the very old
are defective in memory.
"They are in a state
of flux, the former
because of their growth, and the
latter owing to their decay."
He went on to explain
that like running water,
no impression would
remain in younger persons.
And in older persons,
the impressions
would be inscribed less well
because his receding surface
would be frayed or deteriorated.
Now Montaigne, someone
somewhat closer
to the present, who
is described often
as the father of
modern skepticism aptly
commented on issues
of aging and memory,
particularly with respect
to his own aging memory.
As you see here
and, he says, "I'm
obliged to call the
men who serve me
by the names of their
offices or their provinces,
for I find it very hard
to remember a name."
This very clearly
describes something
that has come to be called
tip of the tongue phenomenon.
And it's a very active
research area currently.
It's a state when
you just can't quite
recall the name of a
person that you know
or a word that describes
the essence of what
you're trying to express.
It just doesn't come to you.
So this happens increasingly
frequently as we age.
Now, before we fast-forward
to the current views
about the brain and
mental competence
during aging, what I need to do
is give you a few definitions
so we're all on the same page.
So we'll start with we'll
start with senescent.
It's a word that refers
to an organism of old age.
It carries no necessary
implication of infirmity.
Senile, on the other
hand, is a word
that implies dementia
or mental incompetence.
And dementia, of course,
describes a range
of symptoms that can be
caused by specific diseases
and results in a
decline in memory
and other skills severe enough
to affect your daily life.
Now, the most common
forms of dementia
are Alzheimer's disease, which
has a specific pattern of brain
pathology that's characteristic
in the individuals that
have it, and it tends
to have a gradual onset.
The other main form of
dementia is vascular dementia,
which is caused by
one or more strokes
and is typically
more abrupt in onset.
Now, even 50 years ago, the
prevailing view of old age
was that if you
live long enough,
you would become senile.
And today we know that
becoming senescent
does not imply senility.
Alzheimer's disease and vascular
dementia are not inevitable.
Now, when I talk this
evening about aging,
my focus is on
aging of the brain
and what this means for
successful mental lifespan.
This is a complementary topic
to the longevity and lifespan
extension that you
heard about last week,
the lecture from [? Yanko ?]
[? Nicolet ?] [? Zugic. ?] Now
my focus is on the brain,
so let's go to the brain.
The brain is composed primarily
of two types of cells, neurons
and glia.
Example cells are shown here.
The magenta-colored
cell is one nueron
in the olfactory part of
the moth brain that responds
to many, many different odors.
And the green-colored cell
is one complex glia cell
in the same part
of the moth brain.
Now, these images were provided
to me by good colleagues
here at UA, who do
fantastic neuroscience.
But as you can see, are truly
at the interface of where
science and art meet, I think.
Now a mature human brain weighs
about 1,500 grams, 3 or 3
and 1/2 pounds.
And recent improvements in
whole-brain cell counting
methods have given us
an updated estimate
of the numbers of cells in
each of these categories.
For humans, as of
2009, we think there
are about 86 billion
neurons and 85 billion glia,
about a one-to-one
glia-neuron ratio overall.
I guess-- I'll just
make a comment.
It's nice to talk about
something in the billions
or more that's other
than our national debt.
[LAUGHTER]
So while the glia
neuron interactions
play a critical role in brain
function and in brain aging,
tonight I'm going
to focus on neurons.
And this is because these are
the elements in the brain that
hold our memory.
I need to give you
two more definitions
before we go further.
When I refer to the
cortex of the brain,
this is what I'm referring to.
This is the outermost most
part of the brain shown here
in a human brain.
And in many animals,
this part of the brain
has many foldings,
highly folded, which
gives it an uneven appearance.
F here stands for the frontal
lobes or frontal cortex.
T, for example, stands
for temporal lobe
or temporal cortex.
And what you can't see from
the outside of this picture
are the areas and
underneath the cortex.
And these are referred
to as subcortical areas.
These are examples of--
now you've gotten
all the definitions.
These are human cortical
cells, their neurons
from the temporal cortex taken
from people of different ages.
And this is history.
This is a summary
of what was thought
to happen to neurons during
the aging process when
I became interested in aging
in memory in the early 1970s.
Now before I describe
this in more detail,
I need to give you
one more definition.
You may know that
neurons are what's
called postmitotic cells.
They do not re-enter
the cell cycle
like, for example,
skin cells do.
And because neurons do
not undergo cell division
after they're formed, they do
not show telomeric shortening
like other [INAUDIBLE]
tissues, which
you heard about from
both previous speakers
in this lecture series.
So your neurons are born
largely before your birth,
and they die with you
at the end of your life.
So if this classic view of
brain aging was correct,
then neurons of a
20-year-old maybe up to 60
would look pretty good.
But this example cell
from a person who was 90
would be very shriveled, and
presumably, dysfunctional.
Now, by the way, this picture is
still in many textbooks today.
But we know now that this
depiction of brain aging
is wrong.
[APPLAUSE]
This is because-- yes.
This is because the
data that supported
these conclusions were flawed
for at least three reasons,
and I'll tell you why.
First, the early
experiments included
people who had a dementing
illness of some sort, probably
Alzheimer's disease.
So they use
contaminated samples.
Second, the cell
counting procedures
that they used in these
early studies were faulty.
We now have new, mathematical
assessment approaches
for counting cells free
from artifacts that
were a problem in the past.
And finally, and probably
the most disturbing,
is the fact that there may
have been experimental bias
in these studies.
Now, no scientist sets out
to have experimental bias.
But unless you actively put into
place methods that prevent you
from influencing your
own measurements,
it's possible to confirm your
own experimental expectations
Inadvertently.
Now, an example of
this inadvertent bias
might be if say your
expectation is that there is
cell death in the aging brain.
Then you might notice more
shriveled cells in a brain
that you knew was old than
in the brain that you knew--
that you thought was,
or knew, was young.
One can do this
quite unconsciously.
Interesting to this audience,
perhaps, is the fact
that this scientist,
Paul Coleman,
who uncovered the problems
with these older studies
is currently here in Arizona
at Banner Sun Health Research
Institute.
I met Paul at a
conference in Luxembourg
in 1979 where these ideas about
neuron degeneration and aging
were just being
presented and debated.
In this old photograph--
there's Paul and there's me.
[LAUGHTER]
And in his lecture,
Paul presented
data that did not support
the picture of deteriorating
neurons in older
individuals that I just
showed you previously.
Rather, in his lecture,
he attributed his findings
to the fact that first he used
individuals who were aging
normally, were not demented.
Second, he uses these new,
unbiased cell-counting
methodologies, and he used
an experimental design that
required him to be blind to the
identity of the group in which
he was counting cells, so he
was blind doing his cell count.
In fact, in the end,
Paul saw just as many
of those shriveled neurons in
younger individuals, younger
brains, as he did
in older brains.
Now I must say, at
this meeting, his data
were met with a
lot of skepticism
by those who held onto the
dogma that aging essentially
is equivalent to disease.
Now, I think that if you
were here last week and heard
[? Yanko ?] [? Nicolet ?]
[? Zugic's ?] lecture,
he provided compelling
evidence last week that aging
of the body is not
equivalent to disease.
And I'm about to
describe why this is not
an appropriate analogy
for the brain either.
But first, you need to know
what an old person who is, so--
[LAUGHTER]
Later, I'll tell you what
old is in other mammals.
But for people in
the United States,
the age at which you're
considered to be old
was statistically determined
by actuaries in 1935.
And at this time, the prevailing
norm of retirement age
was 65 years.
So when the social
security system
was launched in that
year, the US committee
on economic security selected 65
as the official retirement age
from surveys of existing
pension systems.
Now the life expectancy at
birth in 1935 was 62 years.
But today, 65 has remained the
conceptual transition point
into old age.
And 65 is actually used in
most studies of the aging
brain in cognition today to
define at least a young-old age
group.
But the actual age
at which people
choose to retire now,
as everybody knows,
has been creeping up,
along with life expectancy.
Now as you've already heard
about from both other lectures
in this series, life expectancy
at birth in the United States
is currently around 78 years.
Japan is the oldest
large country,
with an average life expectancy
of birth of 82 years.
And the United
States is about 50th
in line, in terms of
longevity as a country,
while micro states like Monaco
have a life expectancy at birth
close to 90 years of age.
Now, you'll be hearing
much more about this
from [INAUDIBLE] in a subsequent
lecture in the series.
Now as an aside, when you're
looking at life expectancy
figures, these figures
can be very confusing.
So I just want to draw your
attention to two things
quickly.
First, you need to pay
attention to whether this
is an average of male and
females longevity figures.
So this is the average.
But females, on
average, live 81 years.
Male, 76 years in
the United States.
And you also need
to pay attention
to whether it's calculated
from birth, as it is here,
or whether it's calculated
from a different age.
So say from 65, of course,
the life expectancy goes up.
If you live to 65, you're going
to make it, probably, to 84.
If you live to 75,
to 87 and so forth.
So just for your
own information.
OK, defining prevalence.
What we're interested
in with respect
to this particular lecture
is normal brain aging
distinct from diseases
of the brain that
can affect mental activity.
And for dementia, the aging
demographics and memory studies
is the first study
in the United States
that used a nationally
representative sample
across all of the United States.
They included individuals from
all regions of the country
and used very rigorous and
time-intensive assessment
tools.
So here are the best
figures that we have.
In the United States, 14%
of people 71 years and older
have dementia of some sort.
Considering all dementias,
if you take this 14%,
all dementias Alzheimer's
disease is the most prevalent
at 70%, and vascular
dementia is next at 17%.
Now, the prevalence of
dementia, of course,
depends on the age
bracket you consider.
If you look at the age 71
to 79 years, only 2.3% of us
will have Alzheimer's disease.
Whereas if you look at the
age range over 90 years,
it will go up to 30%.
Now, the actual numbers
of people over 71
who have dementia, those
14%, is staggering.
But one must keep in perspective
that a rather small proportion
of us will be demented
at the average life
expectancy of 78 years.
That is about 5% in
the United States.
So for this talk, I'm going
to leave discussion aside
concerning these 14%.
And what I'll focus on
for the rest of the talk
is what happens to the
brain and cognition
in the rest of the 86% of
us who are aging normally
and who may live to 100.
Now, you might ask, well,
what do you mean by cognition?
Well, I'll just
briefly describe it.
Cognition involves taking in
information and remembering it.
It involves applying knowledge
gained through experience.
It involves making decisions
and changing preferences.
All these things.
So the focus of this
talk is I'm going
to really focus on the memory
component here for today.
All right, what
I want to do next
is to review some
fundamental observations
about brain aging that
hold true across mammals
and are critical for
human aging and memory.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
Whoops.
And this slide--
where's Joaquin?
This slide-- I've shown
you first a human brain.
Next, a baboon, an elephant,
a zebra, a sheep, and a rat.
And many of you are probably
going to be really disappointed
with me.
I looked high and low.
But as Shane Bridges introduced
you to the naked mole rat
in his lecture, but I couldn't
find a whole photograph
of in any of the
brain collections
that I had access to.
So we don't have
the-- whoops, sorry.
We don't have the
naked mole rat.
So even though today
no one believes
that somewhere around 65
years of age senility sets in,
and which is a commonly held
view only several decades ago,
most now believe that even
if one is disease-free,
there are lifespan
changes in memory
that we should expect to happen.
And these, of course, are
at least slightly annoying.
Right.
Different cortical regions,
different regions of the cortex
are involved in different
cognitive functions.
And these cortical
regions develop
and they age differently
at different rates.
So, for example, if you
take the frontal lobes
that I pointed out
to you earlier here
in the human brain,
this region of cortex
is the last portion of
the brain to develop.
And it's only mature in
your early 20s or so.
And interestingly, this area
of the brain is among the first
to show a decline during aging.
It's, in fact, this
frontal cortical region
that's involved when you,
say, walk with determination
to the kitchen, you have to do
something, and then by the time
you get there you
forget what it was
that you were determined to do.
And what you'd planned
to do, of course,
was to take out the lunch
from the refrigerator
so you wouldn't forget it
on your way out to work.
And this kind of memory
is called working memory,
where you're trying to
keep something in mind
for a short period of time.
And this depends on structures
within this frontal lobe
region.
So while I want to make
you aware that there
are important changes with
aging in the frontal cortex,
and actually, in a number
of other important brain
structures, the
focus of this lecture
will be on a structure
in the temporal lobes
down here, specifically,
the hippocampus.
OK, so the reason for the
focus on the hippocampus
include the fact that the
biological mechanisms of memory
were discovered
in the structure.
And the hippocampus is
thought to be the main gateway
to lasting memories
in the brain.
Furthermore, changes
in the hippocampus
are known or a major factor in
age-related memory impairment.
This is a picture-- it's a
beautiful picture, I think,
of the hippocampus in a
cross-section of what's
called a brainbow
transgenic mouse, where
different colored
fluorescent proteins can
be labeled in different subsets
of neurons in this structure.
You might ask, how do I
know that the hippocampus is
critical to lasting memories?
Well.
One answer to this question
is that the hippocampus is--
if the hippocampus is damaged
in humans or in other animals,
memory is severely impaired.
There have been a number
of famous amnesic patients
who were unfortunately to
have both hippocampi removed.
And from then on,
effectively, they
could not lay down
any lasting memories.
[INAUDIBLE] amnesics are left
with old memories and episodes
of experience that were stored
elsewhere in the cortex.
But they can't incorporate
new experiences.
One specific type of memory that
the hippocampus is involved in
is spatial memory.
It's kind of memory that
allows us to find our way
through our environment.
It's the kind of
memory that will
allow you to find your car when
you get out of Centennial Hall
or to point to the stadium--
I might be wrong--
the stadium from here.
So an example of how we
know the hippocampus is
critical for navigation
and spatial memory
is a positron emission
tomography study, a pet study,
that allows you to measure brain
activity bioglucose metabolism.
Eleanor Maguire and her
colleagues in London
had taxi drivers recall
a route that they
could take if they were
told to pick someone up
at a specific location,
say, a Grosvenor Square,
and then to drop them off
somewhere else, say Elephant
and Castle.
So they would just
recall these routes
while they were in the scanner.
And when the taxi
drivers did so,
the right hippocampus was
powerfully activated, seen here
in three different brain levels.
This shows the
average activation
over 11 taxi drivers.
So these are the kind
of data to support
the idea that the
hippocampus is fully engaged
in spatial navigation.
Now, I just want to
segue here a bit.
Spatial learning and memory,
and why emphasizing it,
has been very, very important
for the study of the biology
of memory and how that kind of
how memory changes with age,
because it doesn't
require language.
Because this type
of memory can be
tested under similar
conditions across species,
spatial memory can be
studied in some detail
in animal models of aging.
Now rats are not good models
of tip-of-the-tongue phenomenon
that Montagne complained of,
but they are great for learning
about the brain mechanisms
of spatial memory.
Now, the subtitle
of my talk today
might be that aging
memory doesn't just
happen to those of
us who can study it.
But it happens across
the animal kingdom.
Because of this, we
can learn a great deal
about the fundamental
principles of aging brains
by studying animals who
also show brain and memory
changes as they
reach the maximum
of their respective lifespans.
OK, unfortunately-- so I
have to tell you again,
unfortunately, the spacial
cognition of the naked mole rat
has not been studied.
[CHUCKLING]
No.
While they appear to
be cancer-resistant,
they are resistant to a number
of forms of oxidative stress
and they live for a very
long time for their size.
We do not know whether their
genetic makeup also prevents
brain and memory changes
with age, something actually
that should be studied and
may be worth a trip to Kenya
or Ethiopia where they live.
So a number of
tests have been used
to show that the acquisition
of new spatial maps
is defective in older
ages and across species,
and most of these studies
involve spatial navigation.
So I'll give you examples
in the rat, in the monkey,
and in the human where
spatial memory has been shown
to be impaired during aging.
OK, my choice of
memory tests to show
you is an example for rats.
Can you imagine having a rat
apparatus named after you?
I mean, this is not something
to be proud of, probably.
Anyway, we developed this
task in the mid-1970s,
specifically for old rats.
The object is to
navigate to one place
where escape is possible
into this dark box.
Rodents really don't like
brightly-lit. open spaces.
And so they learn to find
this dark escape box.
So the rat begins
by being let out
of the can in the
middle of the circle.
And then he makes
a couple of errors,
and then he finds it and
descends into the escape box.
So the consistent finding
here between age groups
is that old rats do not remember
this location of this tunnel
from day to day as well
as do younger animals,
suggesting a spatial
memory deficit.
Now for rats-- I told you I
would tell you what an old
rat--
other animals-- defined aging
and other animals as well.
And the definition
of old in the rat
is typically the 50% mortality
point, which is equivalent
to about 65, 70 human years.
And for the rats that I study,
it's about two years of age--
two years of age.
So the very much more popular
spatial memory task, actually,
for rats--
and partly because it's faster
to train, more expedient,
is the Morris swim task,
which I'll show you now.
And I don't know
whether you know,
but rats are actually
rather good swimmers.
And, in fact, in
the wild, they've
been observed to
catch fish in streams.
And in this task, they can learn
to navigate to the one place
in the pool, which
is here, where
there's a hidden platform.
Again, old rats show less
accurate spatial memory
compared with young
rats on this task.
For example, if a young
rat was put in the pool,
they would take a
bee line directly
for the platform from
where they were released.
So old rats have
visual memory deficits.
Monkeys are also a good
model of normative brain
and cognitive aging in
humans for many reasons,
but for the purposes
of this talk,
it's important that,
of course, there's
a high degree of
similarity between brains
and these primate species.
And they also show spatial
memory impairments in aging.
Now, just in case
you are wondering
whether these performance
changes in aging
may be due to changes
in motivation,
maybe the older animals
just have some wisdom,
they just don't want to
play our silly games.
I want to show you
a video clip of one
of our old and wonderfully
engaged monkeys.
She's doing a complex visual
discrimination problem.
These LEGOs are hard
for me to discriminate,
so you want to do the movie now?
So she-- whoops.
Yeah, nope.
Nope.
Can you put it right on the--
yeah, there you go.
So the door is up,
and she gets it right.
She gets her gummy bear
strawberry she really,
really likes.
And sometimes she
doesn't get it right.
Now, for bonnet macaques
or recess monkeys,
you multiply their age by 3 to
get the equivalent human age.
So a 27-year-old
monkey is equivalent
to an 81-year-old human.
So clearly, these old
animals really enjoy
coming out and playing
and are highly motivated.
So most important
for this talk is
the fact that monkeys also
show spatial memory impairments
as they age.
When old recess macaques have to
remember where they've already
acquired food in one of these
food boxes around the platform,
they have to remember
where they've gotten it
and not to go back
to that place.
Old monkeys make
many more errors
than young, the data being
consistent with the poor use
of spatial navigation
strategies in these animals.
For humans, I will show you
a study conduct but conducted
by Mary Newman and Al Kaszniak.
Al gave one of these lectures
in the Mind and Brain series.
Older adults in this experiment
also showed memory problems
in a task analogous to
the circular platform
in the swim task
that I showed you.
This human test involved
remembering where in the room
to place this marker pole.
So they go in with the
experimenter into the room.
The participant and
the experimenter
go in, look at all
the cues, see where
the pole is, they
take the pole out,
and then have to
replace that pole.
And older adults were not
as accurate as younger
participants in finding a
consistent place, an accurate
place for the pole.
So this is at least consistent
with spatial memory deficits
in older people.
So the point to
take home here is
that in all species
that have been tested,
there are changes
in memory and tasks,
suggesting that
the hippocampus is
a structure vulnerable to
normative aging process.
Now, why do I think
this is important?
I think is really important
because of all animals,
it's only humans
that spontaneously
develop Alzheimer's disease.
And so other animals
who, by definition,
are Alzheimer's disease
free, do show memory changes
across the lifespan.
So we can make the inference,
then, that changes in memory
are a normal part of
the aging process.
So what happens in
the aging hippocampus
to cause these kinds of
spatial memory changes?
Well, this next slide shows
three hippocampal cell types.
These are neurons
from the rat, and all
are filled with fluorescent
dye, granule cells,
and two different types
of pyramidal cells.
And one thing we can
be confident does not
change or contribute to
hippocampul-dependent memory
impairment is cell loss.
Because when
hippocampal cells have
been counted, such as these,
in rats, mice, dogs, monkeys,
and humans, we keep the same
numbers of these neuron types
across our entire lifespan.
There's more good news, at
least for those of us who
are hoping to age successfully.
And that is the fact that many
cell functional properties
are very well-preserved
in the aging brain.
In animals, it is possible to
examine activity of live tissue
in vitro or in a dish.
You can take-- the
hippocampus can
be kept alive with artificial
cerebral spinal fluid
and oxygen for about a day.
And with these
techniques, we've found
that most biophysical properties
or electrical properties
of these neurons
are quite intact.
So the old cells are healthy.
And if you didn't
know which dish
had the tissue from the
older rat or the younger rat,
you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between these,
in large part.
So the question is, then,
what is normal aging?
If, at least in the
hippocampus, there's
little cell loss and the
cells that remain are healthy,
why do we have memory change?
Well, to understand
this, we need
to ask a question
about how memories
are formed in the brain.
Now, we've already
reviewed the fact
that the brain is composed of
171 billion cells, about 86
billion of which are neurons.
Now neurons are made up of three
primary compartments-- the cell
body here, which contains
the nucleus and most
of the genetic
material of the cell,
the dendrites, which
receive most of the input
from the incoming information
from other neurons,
and the axons, which
transmit information
from one cell to another.
Now, most communication
in the brain
occurs by one cell sending
electrical impulses
from this axon to the next cell.
And you may have
heard about this
or learned about this
from Leslie Tolbert
when she gave her lecture on her
talk in Mind and Brain series.
Now, at the end of
the axon, the signal
causes synapses to
release chemicals
across a small gap, which
cause electrical disturbance
in the next cell.
Now this is one synapse at high
magnification you see here,
very high magnification.
It's one micron across.
And while you do not lose
hippocampal cells as you age,
older humans and other animals
where synapses been counted
have found to lose synapses.
So in aging, you do lose
these synaptic contacts.
So one reason the brain
network communication
is changed during aging
is because there's
a loss in the numbers of these
connections between neurons,
loss synapses.
But how is memory stored
in these brain networks?
Well, the famous Canadian
psychologist, Donald Hebb,
predicted in 1949
that the alteration
in the strength of the
synaptic connections
is the change in the brain
that underlies memory.
Now, another way to
remember this is--
one way to remember this
is a saying that Carla--
that can be attributed
to Carla Shatz, that is,
cells that fire
together wire together,
implying that
synapses that converge
onto the same cell of a neuron
will become strengthened.
And another way
to try to remember
this is also from Carla--
out of sync, lose your link.
And this implies that the
timing of the synoptic activity
is critical for this synoptic
strengthening to occur.
Now, Hebb was talking
about this in 1949,
but it was not until 1973 that
the Norwegian scientist, Terje
Lomo, discovered the
biological process that
seemed to fit his postulate
in the mammalian brain.
And this biological process was
called long-term potentiation.
Now, Lomo's discovery
was to find a way
to measure and
modify the strength
of these synaptic
connections in the brain.
So LTP-- LTP is
the strengthening
of synaptic connections, and it
can be experimentally induced
by delivering patterned,
electrical stimulation
to the axons that mimic the
normal kind of firing patterns
that occur in the brain.
This experimental stimulation,
then, results in cells
firing to together and
then wiring together,
the outcome being an increase
in synoptic strength.
When a synopsis is stronger,
it produces a larger
electrical response in the
cell that it's connected to.
And so it's believed then
that a mechanism like LTP
is used by the brain
to store experiences.
Now, if memories are
stored as increases
in synaptic strength of the
connections between cells,
what happens in the aging brain?
Well, when I studied LTP
at hippocampal synapses
in older rats, not only
is there a synoptic loss,
but LTP is changed.
There is altered plasticity
at the synapses that
remain in the older animals.
Under some
conditions, LTP can be
induced powerfully
and effectively
and in both young and--
oh boy, sorry-- both
young and old rats.
But the decay of
this modification
in synaptic strength
is about twice as fast
and the older as it is
and the younger animals.
In this example, about
20 versus 40 days.
And this change in
plasticity mechanism
was correlated with how good
the animal spatial memory was.
So durable, long-term
potentiation
at your hippocampal
synapses was predictive
of good memory in this circular
platform spatial memory task
for both young and old rats.
So clearly, the
plasticity mechanism
used for information storage
in the nervous system
is compromised in old rats.
And this appears
to be correlated
with individual differences
in memory performance.
Now, the changes with age
that I've talked about,
changes in numbers of
synaptic connections
and function or plasticity
of hippocampal connections
obviously could alter the
cellular dynamics of networks
in hippocampal neurons.
Now, the data I'm
going to show you next
uses single unit
recording methods
that isolate the activity of
many single hippocampal cells
at once in a freely
behaving rat.
Now you can use fine electrodes
the diameter, really,
of a hair that can be
surgically implanted into rats.
And the brain does not
have pain receptors.
So there's no sensation to
this insertion of these probes.
In fact, electrodes used in
rats are very much smaller,
but that they're very similar to
those implanted, in principle,
into those implanted in
people to deliver deep brain
stimulation, for
example, to relieve
drug-resistant symptoms
of Parkinson's disease
or in cases of
severe depression.
So the idea is that
you can record activity
of groups of these
hippocampal cells
while the rat's
running through space.
Now, I have to
admit, my old rats
aren't quite as champions
like this Norwegian rat is,
but they do run
around smaller tracks.
And so looking at
how groups of cells
are active when animals
are free to behave
provides just a bit
different window
for viewing how
the brain becomes
modified through experience.
So it's possible to amplify
the small electrical signals
generated by neurons
and to effectively
listen to the symphony of the
brain if you're wired up right.
So next one I'm going
to do is let us all
listen in on the activity
of one hippocampal neuron
as a rat walks around
a circular platform.
So you can see the rat walking
around the circular platform.
He's connected to
the recording system
in the computer by cables.
So let's see if the
movie will play,
and if you can hear the cells.
So--
[SOUND OF CELL FIRING]
--that is the discharge of
a single hippocampal neuron.
And by watching
this video, you can
see that single cells
in the hippocampus
increase their firing
rates when an animal is
in a particular place
within an environment.
And when John O'Keefe
first noticed this property
of hippocampal cells
in the late 1960s,
this is why he called these
hippocampal cells place cells.
Now, the area over which
the cell fires here
is called that
cell's place flied.
And you can see the place field
represented by yellow dots
here.
Now presumably, the
firing pattern, then,
of many cells over
a given space form
to produce a cognitive
map of the environment
that O'Keefe and Nadel described
in their very well-known book,
The Hippocampus As
a Cognitive Map.
You heard Lynn speak in an
earlier Mind and Brain lecture
series, I think.
So when I refer to a hippocampal
map on the next slide,
I simply mean the
distribution of place fields
of different cells over
a particular space.
Now, with new recording
methods partly developed here
in Arizona, many
hippocampal neurons
can be recorded
at once while rats
are running around a track.
And this is a triangular track
that I'm showing you here.
I'm just showing you a
few of the cells that
are simultaneously recorded.
And this is from a younger
rat on two different sessions,
session one, session
two, on the same day.
Now, you see that the
same hippocampal map
is retrieved in session two
as was there on section one.
So the yellow cell
still fires here.
So these are-- the different
cells are different colors,
and the dots are the spikes.
So yellow cell is still
here, the blue cell here,
the red cell is
here, and so forth.
So the young rats retrieve
the same map from session
to session.
And actually, most of the time
older rats also show accurate
map retrieval.
But about a third of the
time for any given old rat,
a completely different
place field distribution
appears when the old rat
goes back into the same room.
It's as though the old rat
had retrieved the wrong map.
And you can see that the blue
cell is now firing over here.
The orange cell didn't
fire at all in section one.
So the observation that
a completely different
neural activity
pattern can emerge
in the presence of the
same physical stimuli
at the very least
indicates that it's
going to be more difficult
to integrate episodes
into the context
in which they're
experienced in older animals.
And this may be partly
responsible for why
older organisms more
frequently become lost.
Certainly, if you're trying
to find your way around Tucson
and you're using
a map of Phoenix,
you're not going to be
navigating very well.
So it appears that--
[LAUGHTER]
--that memory changes
can occur without changes
in neuron numbers and with
high functioning of most cell
properties.
But there are very
specific neural correlates
of memory change that
do arise during aging.
These include fewer cinematic
connections, reduced plasticity
of these connections, and how
the network works together
in the case of the hippocampus
to achieve accurate cognitive
map retrieval.
So clearly, the behavioral
expression of memory
does change with age.
And this appears to be a
normative biological change
in age of populations,
that is, as it
occurs across many mammals.
But if you do live to 100,
become a centenarian, what can
you expect to happen to your
brain and your cognition.
Well, in fact,
studies do indicate
that the longest-lived people
can have high cognitive
function in spite of these
functional changes in the brain
that we've just discussed.
Now today, the oldest living
man is Jiroemon Kimura.
He lives in a small town
in the Kyoto prefecture.
He worked in a post
office for about 40 years.
And he retired and went
into farming, which
he continued through his '90s.
His wife died many years ago,
but he had seven children.
And he reportedly
is particularly
fond of red bean curd and rice.
Now, when asked about
his secrets of longevity,
he says it's his
own interpretation,
but maybe it's due to some
unknown forces of nature.
I don't know.
Now, the oldest person
who is currently alive
is Besse Cooper.
She's a remarkable woman who
received a teaching degree
from East Tennessee
State University
after she graduated
from high school.
And she moved to Georgia
because the salaries were better
in that state.
She married and
outlived her husband
by nearly half a century.
And she has four children.
She says that the secret
to her longevity-- and this
was on her 113th birthday-- was
that she minds her own business
and she doesn't eat junk food.
[LAUGHTER]
So perhaps-- perhaps the
most remarkable example
of this extreme longevity
was Jeanne-Louise Calment,
the woman who was born and
lived in Southern France
to be over 122 years of age.
She ate brie, French bread,
drank red wine her whole life.
She stopped smoking at 90.
[LAUGHTER]
She was 14 years old when
the Eiffel Tower was built,
and van Gogh bought paints
from her family's paint shop.
Now, to give you some
perspective on the changes
that she witnessed
in her life, she
was born when Ulysses
S Grant was president
and she died when Bill
Clinton was president.
So Madam Calment
is the only person
with documented birth records
that has lived to 122 years.
So she represents the
longest-lived person
in our species.
So far, she has no peers.
And another way
of saying this is
that any one of us
in this room has
a one in six billion chance
of living to that age.
[LAUGHTER]
So each of these individuals
that I've just told you about
have exhibited very high
levels of cognitive functioning
at extremely old ages.
And as you learned
about last week,
extending health span of the
body is a fundamental goal
of immunobiologists
like [? Yanko, ?]
and extending the
health span of the brain
and successful mental
lifespan is a fundamental goal
for neuroscientists like me.
So I have told you
that 14% of US over 71
will not enjoy successful
mental lifespan.
But for the 86% that will, how
does this add up when I've just
told you that changes
do occur during aging,
including changes in
memory, changes in the way
the brain stores information,
fewer synapses, and changes
in how networks of
cells work together?
What does this mean
for successful aging?
Well, I can offer at
least one potential answer
to this puzzle.
There has been a
fundamental shift
in thinking about
the brain aging
over the past several decades.
We now believe that
the brain does not just
sit back and
passively deteriorate.
This passive deterioration view
of aging is probably wrong.
We now believe that
in successful aging,
the brain is constantly
adapting in ways that
suggest outright compensation.
And I'm going to give
you two examples.
One animal experiment, one human
experiment to illustrate this.
The animal experiment
is one that I
conducted that started with
the following observation
in question.
We know that some of these
hippocampal neurons from older
rats have lost up to a
third of their synapses.
And the neuron needs a
certain amount of input
to become active and
to discharge a spike.
You know, like that the
spiking you heard in the movie.
Now in the face of
this reduced input,
how do these cells
manage to ever fire?
Well, we were able to show that
the way the hippocampus solves
this reduced input
problem is to make
the individual synapses that
remain in these older animals
stronger so fewer synapses
can discharge that neuron.
So this is evidence for
biological compensation
during aging at the
single-synapse level.
Now at the network
level, the observation
is that retrieval of
salient past experiences,
say, from last week, a
year ago, 10 years ago,
can be quite good
in older people.
The hippocampus participates
in the encoding and retrieval
of this type of
information, and we
know that this part of the
brain changes with age.
We've just spent the last 45
minutes talking about that.
So I'm going to describe
an experiment that
suggests that older adults can
recruit additional circuits
to achieve accurate recall.
So Maguire and Frith designed a
study to look at brain activity
during retrieval of old
memories while people
were scanned in the MRI.
Now when participants
in this experiment
were asked to retrieve these
memories in the scanner,
you see that the left
hippocampus was activated,
becomes active in older people--
activated in younger people,
while both the left and right
hippocampi become activated
in older individuals.
So the neural circuits recruited
for equivalent performance
in aged individuals
can be different.
And this may potentially
reflect adaptive compensation
of the aged brain.
Now I've given you these two
examples, one from animals one
from humans.
But presumably,
adaptive changes will
be observed to occur at the
molecular, the cellular,
the network and behavioral
levels in future experiments,
and many people are
working on this today.
So finally, since the brain can
clearly adapt during the aging
process, how can we facilitate
that adaptation and optimize
cognition?
Well, a number of
us working on this
at the University of Arizona
and around the state.
And this is the primary focus
of the research going on
at the Evelyn F
McKnight Brain Institute
here at the
University of Arizona.
The primary purpose
of this institute
is to understand the biological
basis of memory decline
in normal aging and to find
ways to promote brain health
and cognition.
So what I want to do now is
just to end with some recent--
so unpublished and
some published work
of colleagues here that are
affiliates of the Institute
and give examples of experiments
that involve exercise,
anti-inflammatory treatment,
identification of gene
pathways important for memory,
and cognitive training.
And so I'm going to start
with Gene Alexander.
Gene is a professor in the
Department of Psychology
and part of the Scientific
Advisory Board for the McKnight
Institute.
Gene and his colleagues
have analyzed
whether there's a
relationship between the level
of physical fitness and markers
of a healthy brain across age.
So they studied 123 individuals
between the ages of 50 and 89,
and he used magnetic
resonance imaging
to compute brain network
patterns that best accounted
for the volume change in the
brain of older individuals
in that study,
which you see here.
After they did
the MRI, they also
determined aerobic
fitness scores
for each of these individuals
from treadmill tests.
And they found that the
better your fitness level,
the less of this aging
brain pattern that you have.
So better fitness, less
of the aging pattern.
Of course, this suggests a
relationship between exercise
and healthy, aging brains.
So if you need a good reason
to go take a daily walk,
this is it.
[CHUCKLING]
It's really quite exciting.
OK, so Lee Ryan.
She's a professor in the
Department of Psychology
and part of the Scientific
Advisory Board for the McKnight
Institute as well.
She also has a really
intriguing new study
suggesting that the control
the brain information
maybe optimal for brain aging.
So Lee and her colleagues
looked at two groups of age
and education-matched females.
They're all living
independently,
age ranges from 52 to 92 years.
And selection of the
participants into groups
was based on whether
or not the participants
used non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs.
The controls did not
use these NSAIDS,
and the NSAID group
obviously did.
The mean drug use was 10 years
for this particular group,
and the minimum was four years.
So let's just look at
the control group here.
There was a significant
decrease with age
in brain volume in frontal,
parietal, and temporal regions,
indicated by these
red shaded regions
here in the very brain
areas that we know play
an important role in memory.
Now, over a similar age range,
if you look at the NSAID users,
this group showed dramatically
less brain volume change,
as measured by fMRI.
So this suggests that there
may be a protective effect
of anti-inflammatory drugs on
age-related decreases in brain
volume.
And these decreases in brain
volume are in gray matter.
That's where the dendrites
and cell bodies are.
But Lee is now using a
different method, diffusion MRI
technologies, that allow a
closer look at the regions that
are connected by the axons.
And she's looking at whether
these connections are
preserved to a greater extent
in the older NSAID users.
And these experiments are
ongoing and quite exciting.
The next study that
I'm going to mention
was a group effort between
the University of Arizona
Translational Genomics, or
TGen, Anderson Health Research
Institute, and Arizona State.
Matt Huentelman--
[CLEARS THROAT]
Oh, boy.
Matt Huentelman, Eric Reiman,
and Heather Bimonte-Nelson all
affiliates of the
McKnight Institute.
Now, my colleagues had been
involved in an extremely
interesting genome-wide
association study in humans--
sorry-- that identified
a gene called KIBRA.
And KIBRA accounts
for a significant part
of the normal variation
in memory ability.
Now, this better memory is
associated with this T allele
in the gene.
This gave a potential
clue to understanding
how to go about trying to
improve or optimize memory
by looking at where this
gene is in the brain
and what biochemical
pathways are
affected by this gene variant.
Important for the
story, KIBRA is heavily
expressed in the
hip hippocampus.
Variants of the KIBRA
gene influence biochemical
pathways that localize
in the synapse.
And so the rationale
for the experiment
was will a compound that affects
these biochemical pathways
affect spatial
memory in old rats?
Now, there were several
existing compounds
that were designed for
other applications that
should have the predicted
effect on memory
if our hypothesis was correct.
One was hydroxyfasudil.
Now this is not used for memory.
It's used for angina treatment.
And, in fact, when
we gave this drug
to old, memory-impaired
rats, this treatment
improved the spatial
memory in these old rats.
Now, there are many steps
to follow this forward,
but it's exciting to know that
we're beginning to understand
enough about memory
to predict how to have
a positive impact on it.
OK, so finally I'm going
to mention an experiment
that Veronique Bohbot has
been given a pilot project
funding for through
the McKnight Institute.
She developed a virtual
reality environment
with computers that consists
of an eight arm radial maze.
You see three different
views of it here.
It's surrounded by landscapes,
distal landmarks, trees,
the sunset, and mountains.
And this navigation
training program
is working well in
young participants,
and it can be administered
in the MRI scanner
so that the brain
activity can be monitored
across learning and training.
Now, with different
versions of training,
she can give subjects
practice solving the task
with a strategy
that specifically
exercises the hippocampus.
Or she can use a strategy that
engages a subcortical structure
of the caudate nucleus.
Veronique wants to train a
number of parts of the brain
to see if this results
in positive benefits
and across a number of
domains for older adults.
Because the problem
with many training
procedures is that
they don't generalize.
That is, even though you may
be doing your crossword puzzles
faithfully every
single day, it's
not going to help you find
where you left your glasses
a couple of hours ago.
[LAUGHTER]
So Veronique's approach
shows some great promise.
And actually, Paul
Cohen is going
to talk to you about
some ideas that he
has for a
computer-aided training,
I think, in his lecture
later on in the series.
Now, because education
and lifelong learning
is one of the top predictive
factors for cognitive health--
right next to choosing your
parents wisely, actually--
in fact, all of you
who are here tonight
are doing your part in keeping
those synaptic connections
of yours exercised.
And so for those 86%,
the best advice that I
can give you is
to attend lectures
such as this one and others in
the series, or if not so much,
well, keep engaged in
other stimulating activity.
But the main message is just
to keep those synapses active.
Now David Armstrong will
have an exciting lecture
for you next Tuesday
on the current ability
to replace various body parts.
I don't think he's really quite
up to brain transplants yet,
but-- but you'll have to
come next week to find out.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm sure Carol would like that
answer some of your questions.
Maybe a few questions
from the audience?
Hello.
My question involves medications
that improve brain function.
You mentioned one.
My own doctors
prescribe Aricept,
even though I do not
have Alzheimer's.
Can you address that?
Is it-- so don't seem
to be [INAUDIBLE].
It's interesting
that you say Aricept,
because in normal
aging, actually,
the cholinergic system,
which Aricept addresses--
it modifies it.
In normal aging, you have
a reduction in this system.
So just because-- if you
see any improvements,
that's probably just a
part of normal aging.
So I think that there
are many agents out there
that can improve memory,
even in normal people.
But you have to take into
consideration, of course, side
effects and things like this.
And so have to be careful.
But it's probably
not a bad thing.
Cara?
Sorry.
Yeah, hi.
I was just wondering-- when you
were showing pictures of all
the different brains--
it's a two-part question.
One, is what is the purpose
of the worm-like brain
folds that you see
in all the brains
except for the rat brain?
Yeah, it's very smooth.
And the fact that you do
all the testing on rats,
or a lot of the testing on rats,
and they don't have the brain
folds.
What's the comparison there?
Well, we had a wonderful
evolutionary biologist
try to explain the
brain folding question.
And there are some
animals that do not show--
and I'm blocking on the name
of the animal-- darn-- that
don't show really high
levels of behavior
but have lots of brain folding
because their skull is quite /
so we think that the brain
folding is because of the skull
size, so it pushes the
brain in on each other.
But, of course, particularly
the frontal lobes of rats
are not well-developed.
But non-human
primates-- monkeys--
are quite well developed,
and they show similar memory
deficits as do humans.
But spatial memory is quite
nice because, the hippocampus,
in fact, doesn't have
all that folding.
It's in the bottom of
the brain, and it's
very well-conserved
across species.
It's a very old structure.
So that's why it's particularly
good to study that across age.
I have a question up here.
OK.
What about people who never
had good spatial memory--
[LAUGHTER]
And is there some
kind of genetic defect
has nothing to do with aging?
I know.
So actually, this is
opening of a can of worms.
But actually, it's very
characteristic, even in rats.
I'll put it that way.
Rats-- you can make them seem
brilliant spatial learners.
If you have a lot of proximal
cues-- sort of landmarks
around the water pool, you can
make them look really good.
And you can make them look
really bad with distal cues.
And the male rats look really
good with these distal cues.
So there are sex differences
in spatial memory
between males and females
rats, males and females humans.
You know, there's
always exceptions.
But yeah, some people do have
better or worse spatial memory.
And it may be that you
didn't exercise it when
you were younger or something.
I don't know.
Carol?
So where are the mics?
Sorry.
Hi.
Thanks a lot for the lecture.
It was great.
I was wondering,
I had one question
I have a lecture and
one general, if it's OK.
The loss of volume--
you said there's the
same number of neurons
in the same and glial cells
and that sort of thing.
But then you talked about the
volume of the brain is less--
Yep.
First question is,
what causes that?
And then my second question
is about mycelium and the loss
over time, the sheathing around
Myelin.
Yeah, myelin.
Yes, thank you.
Yes, yes.
OK.
That's what I'm trying to say.
OK, so I didn't
express this clearly,
but the volume loss is
probably synaptic contact loss.
OK, so you do lose synapses.
And if I lead you to
believe that there
was no neuron loss in the brain
at all, that would be wrong.
So let me clear that up.
So in some parts of the brain,
like the frontal cortex,
there probably is actual
neuron loss with aging,
but not in the hippocampus.
So it's probably the
connections overall
plus a little bit of neuron
loss in other brain areas
that makes the volume smaller.
But in terms of myelin,
actually demylinating diseases
do produce real,
cognitive deficits.
But it's not been demonstrated
that this is a primary cause
of age-related changes.
For example, you know
the action potential.
Is the cell spiking?
The volume of those
spikes and so forth
that the velocity and so
forth, it seems to be the same.
So there isn't much
demyelination in aging.
Now, there are these
white-matter hyperintensities
that you see in
humans that we're
trying to figure
out what that means
and whether there is
frank degeneration.
But when you do lose synapses,
you do lose those axons.
So it could be
partly demyelination
of the axons where you're
losing the synapses,
too, that you do see.
Carol, thank you so very
much for a great lecture.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much,
all, for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]